للعثور على الحياة البرية في باتاغونيا وتصويرها ،
اعتمد الفريق على
أدلة خبراء محليين ومتعقبين ،
أخذ أحد العلماء على وجه الخصوص
أطقم العمل إلى المواقع النائية
بحثًا عن كائنات لم
يعثروا عليها قط بمفردهم
[موسيقى]
أطلقوا عليه اسم عالم الحشرات المباحث
غير عادي إيساي مادريس
أنا متخصص في الذهاب إلى مناطق من
العالم لم يسبق أن زارها أحد
وأبحث عن أنواع نادرة وجديدة من
الحشرات ، التحدي الذي يواجهه المخرج كيت لوري
هو مواكبته
ويقول إنه ليس عالِمك العادي
إنه في الخارج  بقدر الإمكان
، سيصعد إلى أعلى مظلات الأشجار التي
تحزم الأنهار
مثل الأنهار الجليدية
لأنه يريد أن يغمر نفسه في
بيئة
الحشرات التي كرسها
هذه المرة
يقود عيسى الطاقم إلى قلب
غابة تشيلي الفالديفية
تتمثل المهمة في العثور
على ذبابة رافعة بدائية ، وستكون
واحدة من أجمل الحشرات التي رأيتها على الإطلاق
[موسيقى]
وهذا يعني تزوير مصيدة ضوئية عالية
في  كانوبي
[موسيقى
] وأين
يجب أن يتبع إيليا ،
لذا فإن فريق الحبال يجهز
الكاميرا الخاصة بي ببعض خطوط الأمان التي تحمل
معدات باهظة الثمن إلى المظلة ،
وهو أمر لا يمكنك القلق
بشأن
تشغيله من أي شيء يتحرك ، فمن
الواضح أنه من الصعب وجود الكثير من
المتغيرات
مع مجموعة الفخ ،
يبدأ إسياح في ترتيب سريره
[موسيقى
] يصر على النوم في الأشجار
حتى يتمكن من التحقق من المصيدة عند الفجر ،
لذا كم مرة كنت تخيم طوال
الوقت الذي بدأت فيه عندما ذهبت إلى الجامعة
ولم أستطع تحمل التكاليف  مسكن
لذلك قمت للتو
بوضع أرجوحة شبكية على الأشجار
ونمت هناك ، فأنا أحبها حقًا إنها
هادئة حقًا وتمنحك منظورًا مختلفًا
عن العالم الذي تعرفه بالتأكيد
(الموسيقى)
حيث تشرق الشمس فوق المظلة
تعمل بالفعل في  معمله الميداني المرتجل
مثير
للغاية وقد حصل على ما أتى إليه
هنا لأنه رائع حقًا إنه مثل
تنين صغير
[موسيقى]